[Music]
hey what's up guys my name is the Shonan
welcome back to another vlog today I'm
going to be talking about one of the
most frequently required the topics I
get and that is how did I start
programming so like I've been in so many
forest slightly you guys enjoying these
pretty much daily vlogs I mean it's been
pretty crazy week I'm currently in
Europe and I will be for like the rest
of the month and half of August as well
there's just so much stuff out here so
many beautiful places in Europe I mean
check it out or should I say check it
out not even a sunny day in fact it's
kind of dark you know the only reason I
brought those classes was so I could do
that that thing I need help so how did I
start programming so I started
programming when I was about 16 yeah I
was 16 year I don't know if you want the
whole story or the abridged this is
probably going to be the abridged
because you know be kind of cool to kind
of go into detail and just have like it
to our version of me talking and
everything that probably bore them
though so the abridged version will
start when I was 16 I think I had some
kind of exposure to programming probably
before that but I think that the first
time I actually kind of took it
seriously and started actually learning
it properly for reals because I wanted
to was I think I was 16 so being 16 I
would have been in year 11 in high
school which was the second last year of
high school and I think at that point I
was still kind of trying to decide what
I wanted to do with my life man the
suspense of they're just coming out and
slaughtering me is it weird that I kind
of wish I had a slo-mo cam setup in case
that happened and that's like the first
thing I'm thinking about anyway so the
year is 2011 I'm 16 I'm in high school
I'm trying to decide what I want to do
with my life and back then I was really
really into filming like I loved making
videos I loved trying to make movies
with my friends in fact I remember we
had this thing on Friday night where
after school a bunch of my friends would
come to my place and we would try and
film like sketches and stuff like that
in fact I think there are a few on
YouTube if you look really
and so kind of all of high school I went
through with this notion of I really
want to be a filmmaker I really want to
be a film producer I was really into
visual effects as well so I didn't mind
doing that I just I really wanted to
make it in the film industry and that
was just all I wanted to do with make
videos make movies do that kind of stuff
I was also interested in computers but
it wasn't it was never like an
overwhelming like I liked playing games
but I don't think I ever considered the
possibility of actually making games
myself I don't know whether I thought it
was too difficult or whether I just
wasn't as interested in that as I was in
making movies but I don't really
remember actually I don't know what my
deal was with that to be honest but I
didn't really research how games were
made that much I think I probably would
have like looked it up and seen videos
of like huge teams large companies
making triple-a titles but I don't think
I was never really one thing that I
didn't really feel satisfied about with
the art side of things in terms of like
making movies and all that like I was
doing art subjects these mosquitoes I
was doing art subjects and I just I I
also really liked maps and I like Maps
was one of my favorite subjects I like
my remember I liked it a lot more than
English I even liked it more than some
of the art subjects I was doing like to
me it was just really cool there was
only one right answer and having like
all of that technicality that went into
it I don't know I just it just really
triggered something in me that I just I
loved and so I really wasn't feeling
that satisfied I think with art and
those subjects because I just I needed
something more technical I think about
early 20 like the way that high schools
work in Australia is that the year
starts like in February at the beginning
of the year because our summer is like
December January February so like year
11 would have been from like February to
December pretty much I think I I think I
already started looking into the
possibility of how to make games and
maybe how to learn that but I never
really started learning it I was just
researching it exploring it I think at
that point and I was kind of into
minecraft back then and so I was
following notch on Twitter and I
remember like him doing a lot and air
which is a Ludum dare however you want
to be fancy with the pronunciation
whatever
I'm going to say a lot um dare deal with
it where are my sunglasses deal with it
I could get them deal with it
see that's high production value the
fact that I did that and the fact that I
wasn't lazy and I actually did that
that's why these videos are so good so
nosh was doing a lot of dare and I
didn't know what that was at all at that
point but what I really was interested
in and that was like a lot of them day I
want to say 24 but it wasn't 24 because
I did let him there 24 so it would have
been like 20 or something I don't know
but not notch made this game called Pro
loot of the chambered which was a like a
doom style kind of dungeon crawl again
and I remember I actually caught that
livestream when it was still live and I
was just watching this guy with a
program on his computer and he was just
typing code and like things are
happening on the screen and these pixels
were like playing around and he was
writing these algorithms in code and you
could see the result on the screen
immediately and I was just completely
like I was in awe of this entire thing I
was like that that's amazing
and so I kept watching and then later I
actually found that people had uploaded
videos of the parts that I missed to
YouTube and suddenly like something just
clicked in my head and I thought to
myself I don't know how to program
I don't know Java Java was language that
he wrote this in I don't know Java I
don't know programming I've never
written code in my life I think at that
point I actually had written maybe HTML
and CSS code before you even call that
code but definitely no actual
programming languages at all ever at
that point and I remember thinking to
myself if I sit down and like pause the
video every five seconds and copy down
all the code that he has technically
I'll have a game right because
everything he did that entire process of
making a game from scratch from start to
finish was captured in one live stream
it wasn't like some I think a lot of
people including knotch were doing live
streams of them just developing games
but never from start to finish like it
was just them working on a project that
they had been working on for like a year
and it was a massive codebase obviously
nothing I couldn't understand that but
it is like it was way too much code for
someone who's not a programmer at all to
understand but I remembered that hey
like I can just write down hundred lines
of code and just read them and I guess
I'll learn to understand them I'll learn
how they
and had like having someone making a
game from start to finish kind of
sequentially as they're working through
it that was such a unique experience I
don't think anyone was really doing that
at that point and to me I was like I
don't know something just clinched in my
brain I was like if I do this if I do
exactly what he did I will get the same
result I'll get a game and so that was
really like I think that sparked
something in me because I knew that
there was a way now for me to do it I
don't know obviously I could have like
followed a tutorial or write a book or
but I didn't write I don't know why
nothing really no I never really wanted
to do this until I kind of ran into this
and realized if I do this I'll get a
game and by now maybe it's like June
2011 and I'm I've got quite a bit of
code down I even remember I was at a
friend's place we were playing Modern
Warfare 2 because I was just such a good
game and I was actually like I think a
few friends were over and I was just
sitting like in the same room on like a
desk with my laptop just copying down
the code from the video because I was
like art man I just I need to I need to
get this and it was so cool because it's
different than if I found code on github
right because I'm actually seeing
someone as they iterate over that same
code and improve it and change it and
make it do things like if you just go to
github and you copy all the code like
assuming it's one commit or whatever and
you copy all the code down you do have a
game yes but you have the finished game
you don't have all the stages you don't
have the kind of the infancy of the game
the infant stages of like there are no
textures yet or whatever and that was
the part that really interested me the
fact that is like you can start small
and you just kind of you grow the game
from there and I had something working
but again I I was googling my way all
this time because I had no idea what the
code was doing at all like I had some
ideas because obviously code is kind of
written in English but again I'm no
program I had no programming experience
whatsoever never any books on
programming just I didn't know how to
actually write code myself I was just
copying text and so I bought a book
called Java for dummies there's a link
in the description below to a couple
books that I recommend in fact like
every video I put out has like links to
program books but there are put some
ones that I mentioned in in this video
in the description below if you want to
check them out but Java for dummies was
the name of the book and that was again
because not sure it is code in Java
I was trying to learn what I was copying
because obviously for me like it wasn't
a deal of copying either I was just
copying to learn right I wasn't copping
to release games or anything at that Buy
and didn't know what I was doing I was
just copying because I wanted to learn
and this was almost like someone telling
me exactly what to do so that I could
make a games like when you're following
a recipe to bake a cake you follow
everything step by step and you get a
cake if you've done it correctly and so
here I am following all of this stuff
not knowing any anything about the code
like at all and I realized like this is
cool I've got pixels on the screen and
and to make things even cooler I think I
didn't realize this at the time but
obviously there were game engines like
unity I think I'm not sure about unreal
back then but unity was definitely out
in 2011 but I knew about it and I think
I had downloaded a unity and like a
sample project and I played around with
it but for some reason I didn't like
appreciate I didn't like it was long as
a game maker which I had actually used
in the past that's a story for another
video because I did actually start
making games way earlier than 2011 but
this videos about how I had a
programming not making games so I liked
the idea of this is just a text editor
with text and it code right in Eclipse
and you get a game and the cool thing
was like this was this was especially
for someone new to programming this was
pretty like hefty like he had written
like a 3d software rasterizer like a ray
tracing kind of one that was essentially
very similar to what John Carmack had
done to doom that was my first thing I
ever programmed right I mean again can't
really say that I programmed it
obviously because I just copy the code
but obviously I developed it like I
developed on it and I learned on it and
I tweaked it and such but that was the
first thing I ever wrote was was like a
3d software rasterizer ridiculous I
don't know how I got so far as well
because like that's such a difficult
thing for a beginner to do but I don't
know I guess that's probably why I'm so
interested in low-level tech and stuff
probably like because I just I that's
the coolest thing that that was actually
the thing that motivated me the most the
fact that again 100% this game me right
like there's not everything there is to
this game including how every pixel is
placed onto the onto the screen that is
all in this like in these files all the
code right it wasn't like unity where
you have a unity project file or that's
that to me was just like this is not
like using one of those Hollywood like
moviemaking games to make a movie like
you're not actually making a movie
you're like choosing a bunch of presets
and like that that's what unity was to
me obviously that's not true and I
didn't understand it as much but that's
what it seemed like to me and so I was
like I don't know this doesn't really
feel real it feels like I'm just I don't
know making something using presets so I
really like the technical aspect of it
and I loved learning about all that
stuff so I had my Java book I was
reading all this code and I was
basically learning I was trying my best
to learn and I have no no one no one in
high school you had a program and I'm
not talking about the students I'm
talking about the teachers like back
then I know it's changed now but back
then at least the school that I went to
did not teach programming at all they
had some IT classes that taught PHP that
was as far into programming as you went
PHP like maybe a little bit of Visual
Basic that I certainly never did any of
that like it was pretty much all PHP
there was a lot of HTML and CSS and that
kind of stuff not like don't even think
anyone even used JavaScript at all like
it was just like a few web things we did
database stuff using Microsoft Access ID
ah I don't know like now I know now I
know people are teaching programming in
high school which is really important I
like that
great idea back then no so I it's not
like I could go to someone at school and
be like hey I don't understand his code
please help me and for some reason I
didn't post on forums online at all like
I don't remember myself ever I probably
didn't even know about stuff no I would
have probably discovered Stack Overflow
because I googled so many things about
programming but I didn't I never really
had a mentor or I never really asked
anyone I couldn't ask anyone in person
it was actually one person who anyways
the ZBrush series I can't I can't go
into this that's probably like the gist
of it really I mean that's how I started
programming I found notches livestream
and I copied or stole all the code from
there and then read it all and reading
that code and trying to understand it
man you have no idea how much effort I
put into that halfway through the year
in 2011 and like July we had like a
winter camp
like I full-on printed this source code
I had to like and this was like at this
point this was barely the source code of
like just a random array of pixels on
the screen like this random colors on
the screen some like a game or anything
it was like ten pages maybe of code
maybe less I printed this I put it into
a display folder and I took it with me
to the school cam and I remember at
night I was in my tent with a flashlight
reading that code and I didn't I didn't
know Java right like I'd begun reading
the Java for dummies book I think at
that point so I knew a little bit about
how programming worked but I barely knew
anything but I just I was reading it I
was trying to make sense of the code and
I was like all right cool this message
this this method called that method I
guess so if that's on page three like
literal I'm not I'm not making this
stuff up like that is how passionate I
was about learning I said that's why I
think I went from like having never
written code or just known anything
about programming at all to like writing
code and being able to understand a lot
and probably knowing most of Java in
like six months because I was just
slowly into it you have no idea of an
abridged version this is getting a bit a
bit long and I need to go I think
there's going to be a part two to this
to hang around
[Music]
[Music]